the most popular Republican in the
United States Congress was just knifed
Matt Gates right now and this is exactly
what I said go back to our videos you
know what was it two and a half three
weeks ago when Matt Gates pulled this
thing off where he took eight
Republicans and worked with all of the
Democrats to get rid of McCarthy you may
not have liked McCarthy now now we know
Trump backed McCarthy you may have
thought he was too swampy or whatever I
thought he was doing some good things
Thomas Massie we showed you that video
who's the most Libertarian member of
Congress said this was the most
conservative Congress he had ever been
part of you may not have liked McCarthy
but Gates did make a deal with the devil
here and we're starting to see the
details of that now because even if you
agree with Gates right and you wanted
the Republicans to be much better and of
course we would all want the Republicans
to be better and the Democrats to be
better Gates made a deal with the
Democrats and now the Republican party
is left in tatters uh but but Gates is
mostly pissed at the Republicans who did
not all fall in line with Jordan and to
that end I agree with him take a
look any comment for the PO camera sir
yeah the the most popular Republican in
the United States Congress was just
knifed by a secret ballot in a private
meeting in the basement of the capital
it's as swampy as swamp gets and Jim
Jordan deserved better than that all
right well I certainly agree that Jim
Jordan deserved better than that I can't
speak to the truth of it happened in the
basement of the capital or anywhere else
but this was the fear right Gates you
were going to take out a guy who was
doing some good stuff McCarthy right was
I happy with the Ukraine stuff or
whatever but like basically as Massie
said he was this was the most
conservative Republic in Congress that
we have had in a long long time right he
was tighten the tightening the belt on
some stuff Gates made the deal with the
devil now it looks like the devil's
striking back and we could end up in a
Sit we could we at this point we could
honestly end up in a situation where the
Democrats will end up with the speaker
even though they don't have the majority
because the whole thing is so in
flux